So I'm gonna do two things. I'm gonna do these
steps. I'm gonna draw
my Vector V1, which is
for reference then.
I'll create a transformation matrix. I'll show you how to create a transformation matrix,
by the way.
So I'm gonna create my vectors. I'm gonna go
Vector. This is going to be V sub 1
and it will take us argument a tuple.
So this will be zero 10.
Okay.
Again, I don't need to pass two tuples because by
default it's X and Y displacement is
zero anyway.
I just need to tell where the segment goes where
the second point is.
So at that zero ten, this will give me that straight line like
before.
Then I'm going to draw this Vector. I'm going to go draw the sub
one and
I'm gonna go obj = ax and for the
color just want to make it black.
Because it's the reference effect vector.
Okay, make sure the other libraries are
imported. So I'm going to click on run all.
and then when I scroll down
there was the line now. I want to show you how to rotate this.
45 degrees
so I'm going to create my rotation Matrix.
And comment that line of code.
And if we look at if we look at the reference.
Up there it says that.
We need to have cosine and sine and
sign it cosine. So I already
have the math library in scope.
So I'm going to use math dot cosine. I'll plug
in the values in a second. Then I have math.sine.
Then I have math dot cosine.
Whoops sine and then cosine, right?
The cosines go on the main diagonal.
like so
what number should I plug in here?
And this has to be negative.
so
we can't put 90 because well.
We're not an Apollo coordinate system. So yes, we would have
to convert radian to.
Sorry degree to Radian.
If I show you the polar coordinate system.
Call a coordinate. Of course Pi is the
length of the unit circle
half of that
would be 180 degrees.
So one unit circle is 360 Degrees half of that is
180. I have a 180 would be a pi
over 4.
Right, so but let me just pull up the picture.
So Pi the length of the unit circle, so
three obviously this would be 360.
Zero and 360 are the same.
Pi over 2 is 180.
So half of a unit circle.
And then 1/4 of the unit circle.
So this L shape we get 90 degrees. Our Vector right
now is here our origin vector.
So we want to go 90 degrees clockwise.
Doesn't matter if you go left or right, but the point is to make it rotate 90
degrees.
So let me show you two ways to do this.
Converting from the degree to Radiance, so
that would be math.
Dot Pi Pi is a is an attribute of the math
object over four.
So I'm just gonna take this and I'm gonna call it.
Theta
Oh that pi over 4.
As I meant to put method here.
Okay.
Theta
Theta data
There's my rotation Matrix. Let me activate this code
multiply my rotation as against my original vector.
And then if I want to draw my Vector, I'm just going to go.
draw
V1 sub rotate
obj ax and the C. Let's make
it red.
and
I want to use this implementation.
this one
So if you remember we said that if you
want to convert from Polar to Cartesian.
I mean I already went through this in the start of the session, but
I want to go the other way around.
So I cannot plug in.
the degrees because we're not in a polar coordinate
system, so I have to
Convert the other way around now the radiant well obvious.
It's this but I already know what the length of my Vector is.
It's just him so R is equal to 10.
But if I want to get my Theta I
can use arctan. This is the inverse trigonometric
function. It is denoted arctan or even
tan to the power y to the power negative 1
So these are these two are identical. Okay, sometimes you will see this notation.
Sometimes you will use that notation. I'm going to use the archetype
function to get the Theta.
and together that I'm gonna have to put y over 10, so my Y
is 10
and my ex is
Well y-axis. Well my x is 0
Okay, so let me show you how I'm going to do this.
All right.
So I'm gonna go.
theta equals math
Dot
arc 10 or 810
and the ratio is y over X. So that's 10 over
0 what? I cannot divide.
over zero
So, let me just make it converge to 0
make it as close to zero as possible 0.
One, okay. I want to it's just
an approximation.
This is meant to be cosine.
Okay. There we go.
This is what I was trying to do.
So yes.
I really wanted to show you this implementation because
so that we know we can we can first of all to show
you the purpose of the inverse trigonometric functions and that
this is one way we can convert back.
And go we can alternate from Polar quality Cartesian.
And the other solution is the Radian.
The second method is to do it this way.
This is going from
polar
to Cartesian
and this is
degree to
Radian
Okay, let's try again.
And of course we want this to be 90 degrees. So I'm gonna make this
pi over it.
There we go.